I've never seen anything like it I have  in the beer out there right how did this  wait  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  Kjell over here what the hell how could  this many people be infected this city  is completely cut off isolated don't  look at me like that all right I'm not  infected but right now it's got a  hard-on for the only two stars left in  town they don't need a bleeding heart  like you getting in my way  stars office has to be in this direction  gets worse every night  they don't want the world to know what  they've done oh it's wrong with umbrella  I can't stop alone you gotta get out you  guys are the ones who cause oh come on  we've gotta be dreaming  commitment honesty integrity these are  the core values that create the  foundation for umbrella corn  for the players  you